- So true or false.
I heard that you stabbed
one of your costars.
So that's weird (laughs).
- Unfortunately, that is true (laughs).
So it was my first day on set,
and it's quite terrifying getting
a big Shondaland Netflix job.
You think, "I just don't
want to screw this up."
So they said to me, "You're very tiny,
let's put you in heels."
And I thought, "Yeah, I'll do anything
you want me to do, yes."
It became evident pretty
quickly that with the corset
and the heels, my balance
was not so amazing.
So I was walking along,
and I fell three times,
and the third time, I
was holding a parasol,
which in the wrong hands
is a deadly weapon,
and I fell forward and
stabbed Claudia Jesse,
who plays Eloise Bridgerton, in the hand,
and she just started bleeding.
- Oh my God.
- But she's still my friend,
she's still my friend.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
But yeah, unfortunately,
there was a stabbing
on the first day, and I was guilty.
It was not good.
- I mean, my thing is if I'm
wearing those long dresses,
that's the first, anytime I'm on a stage,
and it's a long dress, I
look at my stylist and go,
"I want the easiest shoes in the world,"
because they can't even
see your feet.
- Yes.
- So I don't even know why--
- Just throw yourself
on the ground, Kelly,
that's all you need to do.
Just be like oops,
(Kelly and audience laugh)
throw yourself over,
and you'll never have to wear heels again.
- Yeah, well and at some
point I just learned no.